oh let me put this away I would write
different games in that Yahtzee
[Music]
all right so would you rather guys
thanks thanks guys wait who what's your
first I don't kick it off you got the
bucket the bucket I see nothing but
confidence with you okay thank you
would you rather find out the love of
your life is a vampire who needs to
drink a gallon of your blood every night
to survive or be single for the rest of
your life mmm I think I'm gonna be
single for the rest of my life I could
do the vampire I think it sounds kind of
sexy away even Andy didn't answer
doesn't no one cares I would do the
single ones the single one okay would
you rather turn into a gargoyle for 24
hours that one every time you eat a
pizza oh wait
or never have pizza again are you
kidding me never eats again never have
pizza again never I would never have
Pete's again I don't wanna be a gargoyle
I don't need to eat pizza guys I'm I am
undiagnosed lactose intolerant so I
think I could let go of the pizza I
don't know I do really enjoy yeah I do
would you do as a gargoyle for 24 hours
I would love to not do anything yeah and
is it like a living gargoyle just do I
get to fly I think you're not even
gargoyle statues so are gargoyles crows
they're really just fat crows if I get
to fly I'm in would you rather live in
constant 150 degree weather every summer
for the rest of your life or if you
turned into a vampire that has to live
for the rest of eternity oh that's tough
I don't think I'd want to live forever
if you could look like this forever yeah
this is good right if you could do this
forever
you wouldn't do this forever a little
bit like there was a question mark in
there I can barely do it now listen
there are humans that live in a 150
degree heat yeah I was born in Texas
vampires technically can be killed stake
through the heart
flaw in that question who wrote that
question you can just go hand me the
snakes just the suburbs it's just a
three to four month goodness you know
what it was as I was trying so hard to
read the question really well it happens
a lot of my Passover say here would you
rather have eyes covering your entire
body or have only one eye located on the
bottom of your foot oh that's too much
work to do this this yeah yeah nobody
needs that big a quiet one I on the
bottom my foot no question yeah I don't
know I'll try though all of those I'm
going one on the bottom of the foot
because otherwise you're just bumping
into stuff you're getting jacked in your
eyes all the time would you rather go on
a road trip from New York to LA with a
five hundred and forty five-year-old
zombie who hasn't showered in five
hundred years or with your most recent
ex
ah I would say my most reason excellent
hands down yeah me too yeah me too
would you rather be a werewolf met
shape-shifts into a wolf every time you
kiss someone god can't take it in court
never be able to kiss anyone for the
rest of your life
werewolf werewolf yeah I would
exclusively hook up with wolves so that
when I change they'd be like now we're
talking this human person who I guess
will do one kiss - oh that's good you
and I are the best singers here we could
teach everyone here a little thing or
two bad thing okay
would you rather be forced to sleep
upside down like a vampire for the rest
of your life or drink a glass of your
own blood with every meal oh the blood
for sure I love it I've been in the
hospital so much so it's kind of like
comforting your weird way really okay to
drink your own blood yeah I don't want
to sleep upside down that's probably
gonna be bad for me well it's like
drugging your own blood cuz although
it's all gonna go to your head anyway
what I just think of like hot blood did
I chill it this
yes is it a can we drink it with ice so
maybe it's like everyday I know I'm
gonna barf blood but then I'm gonna
sleep really right see you're right yeah
you're right yeah would you rather sleep
in a graveyard for the rest of your life
or only be able to sleep for one hour
every night for the rest of your life oh
and it would be very respectful of those
around me absolutely no I would sleep in
if it actually feels very well it sounds
very relaxing to me oh we have one more
would you rather have to survive a
zombie apocalypse for a whole month or
never be able to listen to music again
zombie zombie love zombie movies we've
got all the room we can handle it
everybody can handle a zombie apocalypse
that's not even mishit are you
guaranteed to survive it it's not
details you'll also survive every barely
implies that you would I'm saying if
there's any chance I'm gonna get
attacked by zombies and turn into a
zombie I might choose no music there's
only 723 movies like we just have an
instruction manual out there already
handle zombies there's a whole TV show
but a lot of those movies end with most
of the characters this subjects means
they get eaten they get eviscerated or
zombified except for like a cute couple
and they're gonna start a family and
that's gonna begin again the human race
yeah I could be that that could be used
Selena that could be you
well we did great here solve some
problem we got through it guys think
tank think tank can we keep these laughs
these are ours right to cable thanks
guys
[Music]